the fundraising arm of st. Jude
Children's Research Hospital
Richard Shadyac jr. how are you bud I'm
good okay
I'm doing great Rick and then on the
other line if you can mix it up with the
line 12 right now joining us on the
phone line is the executive EP of
innovation and new technology of CBS
Sports the great legendary Ken a guard
how you doing Ken that's doing great hi
Rick hey Ken so Rick I'd love to just
give you the floor right now and and
have you tell everybody what the legends
for charity dinner means for st. Jude
it's to my knowledge the only event of
Super Bowl week that is dedicated to a
single charity event so you have the
floor as to what it means for you well I
appreciate that give me the privilege of
saying something about you first and and
I just want everyone to know all of your
listeners to know how amazing you are
and you know rich I think you've done
this now four times for us as the emcee
and and it was a privilege for us to
give you the Pat Summerall award last
year and you know again I want everyone
to know that rich he's just not that
pretty face also also he walks the walk
my friends okay I want everybody to know
that rich and has done this run rich run
campaign and he's raised over $500,000
to support the life-saving work done at
st. Jude Children's Research Hospital so
thank you rich all right come on Rick
it's mine it's my honor but tell me
about what people how people can get
involved in what the event means for st.
Jude next week Thursday February first
at the Hyatt Regency in downtown
Minneapolis we're going to be honoring
coach Tony Dungy with the Pat Summerall
award and and you know this is a special
night for us and we honor anybody it's
got to be a person who's shown the same
kind of character integrity and
leadership in their careers as the late
Pat Summerall did and and this is an
annual fundraiser for st. Jude
Children's Research Hospital and it
brings together some of the most notable
sports and entertainment and local
celebrities to raise money and to create
awareness for st. Jude Children's
Research Hospital and we've been doing
this for well over 10 years now and
we're excited
honor Tony and that's what this night's
all about and Ken I'm you know I know
the story but want you lay it out there
for the listeners and viewers of this
show as to why the st. Jude means so
much to you and your family
sure so go again I'm sorry Ken
Rick you can always talk know anybody
I'm a parent of a child who had a brain
tumor called medulloblastoma happened
when she was 11 she's 15 now and it was
st. Jude that we my wife and I mo
believe saved our daughter Ali's life
when it first happens to you and you
know when your child suddenly has a
tumor in their brain and it comes out
nowhere they were doing fine one day
playing soccer and then suddenly the the
next day they're incapacitated and
suddenly you're in a hospital and she's
having brain surgery you don't know what
to think you would become
deer-in-the-headlights you don't know
where to go and we were really fortunate
after her a fair amount of research that
my wife and I did to find st. Jude and
in particular dr. Gujjar who walks on
water with us and we basically moved to
Memphis for six seven months as our
daughter went through chemo and st. Jude
and dr. gage are laid out all the
protocols for our daughter and she is
doing very well right now as a matter of
fact last year she played in the st.
Jude pro-am golf tournament in June I
got the caddy
that's crazy man and and and we really
feel that and you know having spent all
the time in st. Jude as my wife and and
I and our daughter did we we got to be
very close with the family that's there
and that family is
lots of families and it's such a
wondrous place it's it should be a place
that almost everyone should go and visit
it is very uplifting it is it is it is
the place that families want to go and
want to be at when you are in this
circumstance and in this situation
because they can help you with
everything and you can't even pay for
anything as you can
I still can't get over that yeah that to
me is is what really separates st. Jude
can in Ric you know when the minute I
have left for you the fact that the
families never see a bill and then don't
have to worry about groceries don't have
to worry about housing don't have to
worry about anything except focusing on
their loved one getting better and
that's because you're so reliant and
also expert at raising funds Ric and
that's what this nights about next
Thursday it is you know and and I have
to say a special thank you to you and
all of your listeners and viewers
because you ensure that no family will
ever receive the bill from st. Jude not
for the cost of treatment travel housing
or food because all we want are moms and
dads like Ann and in in Emerald and Ally
to worry about is helping Ali survive
childhood cancer that's what st. Jude is
all about Ric I look forward to seeing
in next Thursday legends for charity
comm is how you can buy tickets
obviously go to st. Jude's website to
donate to st. Jude as well and then and
then Ken great season for CBS once again
for football that john malkovich open
that tease was unbelievable that was it
was it was I think I've watched it five
times least radevich is is a genius and
he really outdid himself on this it was
it was fun I was up there in New England
too you were so you know you were on
that shoot 10 oh yeah I'm sitting in the
TV compound in San Diego now about the
Tigers out there someplace okay
ken do you sound like Nance almost right
now so do you haven't do you have a
tiger update from Torrey Pines Jenna I I
actually I've been sitting out here I
don't know what
doing right now I would be died you have
to go on the truck and find out he's won
over he's won over I've just been told
all right hey can I look forward to
hearing your speech as always next week
and Rick I love you guys that at st.
Jude can't wait for next week in
Minneapolis
likewise you got it thanks again you got
us a Ken a guard of CBS Sports
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience